-Now, after six seasons,
you guys have gotten
pretty close.
I wanted to see
just how close you are
in a game we call
Know Your "Schitts Creek."
Here's how the game works.
One of you will wear
noise-canceling headphones
while the other three answer
a question about you.
Then you'll take
the headphones off,
and we'll see
if your answer matches.
Make sense?
-I'm scared.
-Let's do this.
Eugene, the first question
is about you,
so please put these on.
-You have to put it
over your hair, Dad.
-Oh, boy. Oh, boy.
-Okay.
-No, you don't.
-I wonder if it's gonna
touch your hair.
-What's the biggest pet peeve
Eugene had to overcome on set?
-Oh.
-Something to do with food?
-No, his hair.
-Oh, maybe it's the hair.
It's the hair.
Getting his hair wet.
-It's "The Drip."
Getting his hair wet. 100%.
-Yeah, that or working
with his kids.
[ Laughter ]
-Eugene, here we go.
The question was,
what was the biggest pet peeve
Eugene had to overcome on set?
-[ Laughs ]
-No, you can't put it back on!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, "The Drip."
The episode in the show
when my hair's soaking wet
and I have to...
-Wow, that's what they all said.
[ Ding ]
They all said that.
That was it.
-Catherine said your kids
were a close second.
-[ Laughs ]
-A close second.
Nothing comes close to the hair.
Anyway.
-Alright, here we go.
That's it. That's the music.
It's working.
Alright, Catherine.
This is for Catherine.
Alright.
-Wait, wait, wait, wait.
-What's the hardest Catherine
laughed while shooting?
-[ Exhales sharply ]
I would say it was a scene
called "Allez Vous,"
and it was a scene that she --
-She and I were selling
[Clears throat]
cosmetics to the town,
and it was just a sad, desperate
sales pitch that was not --
-But you had some
of the product...
-Dan's face was orange.
-...on his face,
so he looked bronzy,
bronzy, bronzy.
-It was bad. It was --
-Catherine started the scene
and could not look at him
without laughing.
That's my guess.
-You guys agree?
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's the one? Alright.
Alright.
Catherine. Okay.
Alright, ready?
-I was afraid to look
at you 'cause I thought,
"What if I find out
I'm a lip reader?"
[ Laughter ]
I actually kept my face away.
-You just found out now.
-Wouldn't that have been
a wonderful discovery?
-Yeah, but not here.
-The question was,
what's the hardest Catherine
laughed while shooting.
-I bet that's easy.
Um...
I think it was when
Daniel and I were doing
"Allez Vous," and --
[ Cheering ]
[ Ding ]
-Whoo!
-Because he was so --
David, the character
was so nervous
trying to sell this product,
and he had also tested
out the tanning cream,
and it was a yellow, orange,
and he looked like
a goldfish caught in headlights.
[ Laughter ]
-Not wrong.
-I couldn't stop.
I was so unprofessional.
-Those are, like,
the best moments, though.
I love it.
-We are two for two.
Not that I've been counting
or that I'm competitive, but...
-Yeah, you guys know each other.
-They do that. They do that.
-This could have gone
really bad.
Imagine we know nothing
about each other.
Just failed every question.
-Well, here we go.
We have one more.
Alright, on the show, the
Rose family fell from riches.
In real life, how did Dan make
his first dollar?
-Oh, didn't he work at Baby Gap
or something?
[ Laughter ]
-Gap Kids.
-Oh, yeah.
-Aww.
-Well, babysitting before that?
-No.
-No entertaining your guests?
-Uh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Did any of your guests
know you had a son?
-No babysitting 'cause
he doesn't like kids.
[ Laughter ]
-And kids don't like him.
-Another fact.
-Yeah, Gap Kids.
-He's really getting into it.
He's very serious, yeah.
-You guys ready?
Alright, Dan, here we go.
-Yeah.
-On the show, the Rose family
fell from riches.
In real life, how did you make
your first dollar?
-My parents dropped me off
in front of a Gap Kids
and said very clearly,
"Do not come home
without a job application."
And I don't want to say
that that's, like,
motivated me to be
a compulsive over-worker,
but it definitely hasn't
not done that.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
-Gap Kids!
That's correct! Yes!
-Whoa!
Best that we've ever done!
-Oh, my goodness.
-This is amazing. I love this.
-Alright, three for three.
-Annie, it's up to you.
I mean, the pressure's on.
Come on back.
-It's a great song on there.
-Thank you.
-Okay.
-Got it.
-Okay, ready, guys?
-Mm-hmm.
-What's the biggest fight Annie
got in on set?
-A fight?
-Fight?
-What's, like,
the coffee too cold?
-Fist fight with me?
-I would say she's never
gotten into a fight
about anything on set.
-We got to think of something.
She must have.
-I just don't want to
lose the game. Um...
[ Laughter ]
I don't remember a fight.
-Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
-I would say this is
a trick question.
She has not gotten into a fight.
-She's a lovely Canadian girl.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This is so Canada right now.
This is unbelievable.
-I don't know.
We're not into conflict.
-Got you.
-She's, like, too nice
to get into a fight, eh.
-I know. I'm sorry.
-What if she says,
"Oh, which one would it be?"
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here we go.
Let's see if the answer...
Okay, good.
-Okay.
-Making it super anxious
over there.
-Oh, yeah. Tell the truth
on this one.
Boy, oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm scared a bit.
-Oh, so am I.
-Alright, the question was,
what's the biggest fight
Annie got in on set?
-Biggest fight I got in on set?
-Yeah.
-Oh, um...
[ Laughter ]
It was with Dan.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-What?
-Yes, of course.
You're getting close.
-Are you tearing us apart?
[ Laughter ]
-You're close.
-And it was about pizza.
Do you not remember this?
-No!
-We got into, like...
We got --
We got into a heated argument
about which dirty fast food
pizza is the best,
and you got so upset that you
ordered five different pizzas
from five different places
and made us have a taste test
at lunch.
-That is accurate.
[ Laughter ]
I thought more...
-Oh, my God!
Guys, I think that was the best
game of this we've ever played.
You guys really know
your "Schitts Creek."
-Thank you so much.
-Thanks.
-Give it up for the cast
of "Schitts Creek"!